men are struggling chewing with their
mouths open sexual harassment being Shia
LeBeouf thankfully I'm here to help now
why am i qualified is I got a
gender-neutral haircut a popular podcast
and I've had scoliosis welcome to mana
this week we're talking about stress you
know the silent killer
it's like a hungry Mouse inside of a
cheese heart I got a call from Josh one
of our longtime listeners and he said
he's seriously stressed out and
seriously appears to be an
understatement
let's take a look baby get that hitter
Josh really needed a new way to relax
and I knew exactly what to do yeah how's
everything doing asbestos can be you
know yeah morning traffic in a way yeah
yeah yeah man thank you for making the
drive I appreciate it no problem so I
know you're like you know you reached
out a lot of stress going on in your
life what's going on with that um about
14 years ago I was planning on making a
road trip to all the open Major League
tryouts baseball for baseball and I was
working at electronics yeah half a
pallet of computers following me screwed
up my back no way desktops or uh yeah
the big boxes but like that big oh the
inside just screwed up my my dream
career ideas and so just everything is
stressing me out now so the stuff you're
doing right now in the metal with the
bat and everything I get it you know
it's but just kind of old-school yeah
you know it's Rome and it's very used
car dealership violent those ideas are I
made this chart wrong wrong and it said
wrong to us actually scribbled a minute
scribble them out yes thank you
but sometime you have wrong ideas you
got a fold up those wrong ideas and when
you when you make wrong egami and you
fold up those wrong ideas what do you
get left with wrong ro n Ron wrong an
adult's name I'm gonna introduce you
right now to a man named Ron the most
stress-free guy ever all right he's
gonna help us you get it yeah sounds
good alright thanks for being here today
thanks for having ya
bran is the chillest dude that I know
honestly if I had to just curl up inside
of a dude and take a nap it would be in
Ron he's just a smooth silky dark
polyester chocolate throat lozenge of a
man no shades huh yeah and you got nice
eyes too I feel like I'm just guessing
all right um don't hide oh let us see
the windows until your soul see told you
he's calm he is going for me a part of
relaxing is is learning to let go
learning to deal with loss and learning
to give up expectations but never give
up hope you know yeah there's always
things that be found cuz he struggles
this man oh I can see it I can feel the
energy soon as I walked in and change
the things my my plant started leaning
away from him I you're not a bad person
now no yeah you got you got a good
spirit it with you I see it you just got
hurt a little bit yeah and it struck for
you to let that go I understand that I
couldn't imagine what it would be like
if all of a sudden they were just like
hey you just can't do comedy anymore
so I understand it I appreciate we're
gonna get you through it
mmm let's just meditate a little bit
right now
yeah maybe we'll go around the room and
each to release something it sounds
great
perfectionism
being on a first name basis with
different insects in my apartment
in LA traffic having to find a gift for
my assistant that normally purchases the
gifts that I give out is like who picks
out your gift that part of me kind of
mmm
wants to both the oh you guys a
little mmm okay
that's a rug I think we're done that's a
real and I could resonate with yeah yeah
let's just remember that one I mean I
can tell you're just in a deep need of
relaxation and lucky for you I mean
we're in an era where there's just so
many different ways to relax there's so
many different options especially here
in LA you got so many things you can do
you hike you can meditate yoga there's
all types of exercise and if that
doesn't work for you always we wheat is
a great relaxer you know even when Bob
Marley they told him he had cancer he
just said whatever and died
sure a lot of problems in the world
while family I murder but it's also like
this cartoons and
and we could be watching that's a good
point it's crazy to think how many
cartoons are out there and that we're
not watching them at all times well I'm
a firm believer if every TV that has the
news on it like at an airport or
something if you just turned it and put
it on like the Muppet Babies or
something whole world would be a lot
less stress I don't say we wouldn't know
what was going home but who cares
hmm he has a problem up in babies is it
never
you don't know what happened next you
yeah yeah no I just assumed that lump of
babies became the Muppets oh yeah
love we do
a lot of your issues stem from the fact
that you lost something that was very
important to you a dream of yours but
I'm gonna tell you that you can have all
types of dreams and that's what we're
going to work on the day we're gonna
build a little dream board come up with
some new goals help you refocus you cool
with that yeah
[Music]
save this for home okay
now when it comes to picking the right
picture just go on your vision board
you're gonna make sure you there's
something that speaks to you directly
but I got Otis twin boots got me a
cruise ship because I want to go on a
cruise
Abigor II emerald and diamond necklace
that would look good on you thanks it's
fun to do crafts together as men yeah if
you forget how much fun this kind of
stuff is low-key yoked out fellas dreams
with my friends go me feel Josh less
stressed this this helped ya envision it
stuff's fun man but I think maybe we
light into a couple of massages bra like
some true gentleman you know like some
adults you know nothing crazy like
make-your-own-pizza kind of thing you
had him before uh yeah and who was the
person do you remember who they were
what they look like uh name was Tim he
sounds like a good person yeah you gotta
remember if a man touches your body like
that
it's helpful to remember their name they
prefer it yeah probably yeah I remember
the man that touched me Dale it's
beautiful
so you're still thinking about it I
don't know what I'm thinking about man I
wish had a vision board in my head right
now yeah we should get one man we should
get a massage massage massage mm-hmm man
you got a lot more body than I thought
fill that full pressure and those happy
you feel and play out play a quick sound
things change ready
do ya gotta get those thighs man Gang
Gang bruh get it alright our talk right
there on the door so long and now you
work it
I said I'll pull this birthday party
right there don't be afraid that but me
and that old American Werewolf in Paris
bro like that battle over which you got
was you will you rye sourdough
it might be that cinnamon-raisin baby
you know I'm saying yeah good for
breakfast blah blah
let show o television brother I got next
man
[Music]
has changed
never so slight get some ice cream ice
cream
[Music]
now rollerblading is one of the lamest
things that you can do but for some
reason when you're high it's
awesome
it's really just like trying to walk
around in wheeled feet
we had fun we got Wow we wore helmets
but we acted like we did it
where's the Turk over here
job pallies job Josh
had a good time today oh yeah cool man
how do you feel less stressed honestly
sometimes it's just spending time with
other people that's true you know and a
lot of things you were talking about
before it didn't really include those
things you know yeah I mean traffic's a
sedentary environment you know beaten
metal with a bat it's something you do
by yourself masturbation that's usually
something you do alone unless you're
part of a club or synchronized group
it's a funny message when you get out
and about and get going with other
people you know if we quit listening to
the voice in our heads out that boys can
be so stressed out and we just listen to
somebody else
that calm passive beautiful dark dolphin
himself only one thing left to do
what's that I feel like I'm just petting
on bubble baths we strong but gentle
Eliza
I had dreamed it started just like this
today was a lesson in that you have to
open up to let the stress out so how are
you gonna open up I hope you can dream
board you can go look for treasure with
your cousin you can swim you can eat ice
cream with somebody from another country
a lot of different options but try one
Josh did and look what happened to him
you had a good day your comfort zone can
be your coffin I'm Theo von thank you
for listening
you